hey what's going on guys back home hey
and we're doing on another matinee show
today because we actually did manage to
watch a new movie last night and this
was a real good one yeah it's good I
like this movie yeah it's not a horror
movie
they're not any waiting on their first
before beginning there was a okay
probably not a big deal probably I would
just go ahead and go with well yeah like
I said it's like even if people can't
watch it live you know they can watch it
later look I'm sure people that watch it
later don't want to like sit there and
listen to us yeah these nesters all
right all right so the movie we saw is
saying we just picked this completely
and totally at random just because the
cover looked Saks is the audio sounds
rough the audio sounds right did it did
it go back no I checked it it's off I
mean it should be alright I don't know I
can't oh no if I can do anything but how
does the sound exact not sounding good I
mean like I said I put it on that so
okay whatever I can't do anything about
it now yeah well as long as it's uh I
guess it's dad at your stead I don't
know what everybody else here static I
don't know what that would be yeah they
hear static too weird okay hold on audio
sounds good from here somebody says oh
come on maybe it wasn't plugged in all
the way how's that sound
is that any better some people are
saying it sounds good yeah maybe it's I
don't know if it's just something to do
with what if some do the Internet
yeah maybe it's glitching out I don't
know right
I mean can you all can you hear it I
mean is it like is it okay everybody
saying the same I don't know sounds the
same I guess I mean same I guess it
means two sounds bad and then mega batch
that sounds good to me
it's got to be here it's gotta be your
maybe it's some kind of connection issue
more than I the internet feed yeah I
don't think it's the mic the mic is
plugged in and I made sure that it was
cuz I know one time I forgot to check it
and it was went back to the internal mic
I've noticed that
I've noticed that in the beginning of
the feed the video looks real choppy
yeah it takes a few minutes for it to
like catch up get it together
so maybe it's just that yeah I hope
that's all it is I don't know maybe we
should like waiting they say that they
can hear it's just not as good as usual
well ok give it a few they say it still
ok no they can understand it's ok let's
just let's just get it over with
I'll probably sort itself out in a few
minutes yeah sort yourself out because a
lot of times when we start streaming
even the videos kind of choppy yeah I
don't know why I don't know it might you
know it could be a million things it's
some kind of weird technical we saw a
good movie last night it kind of
reminded me it was called mope yeah and
it was kind of like a mixture of what
was the name of that for movie Boogie
Nights and kind of like art of
self-defense
in a weird way instead of it being a
dojo it's a damn porn making like a real
low-rent real world and it's based on a
real this is a true story story it's a
true crime but yeah this was a really
interesting it reminded me very strongly
of Boogie Nights in the way that you
know not only is it set in the world of
porn but it was also it really was kind
of audacious in the way that it was like
a comedy but also a tragedy also really
really tragic yeah and I'm like I'm kind
of in awe of like the director of this
movie because this seems like a really
ballsy like in more ways than one a
really ballsy movie because it seemed
like such a sad like [ __ ] up crime
story to turn into essentially a comedy
but also so true crime also also he
pulled off like the the tragedy and the
sadness of it as well too without
seeming like they were cheapening in or
making fun
or anything like that even though it is
very funny it's a really really sad got
rented it off at Xbox it's brand-new it
was a 399 for standard-definition $4.99
for [ __ ] HD and it's worth every
[ __ ] penny I realize this is a really
good I get it in HD you just just cuz
this looks cool it's about this black
guy and this Chinese guy who are Mokes
and a mope is like a [ __ ]
bottom-of-the-barrel pornstar they're
like porn extras they're like the dudes
that do Pataki's is [ __ ] yes just like
when they need like a whole body the
whole money dudes let's get them and
just get these ramen and evidently they
thought of themselves as the Jackie Chan
and Chris Tucker of porn and the author
themselves are really called back yeah
that wasn't just like they called him
that but there wasn't really much to the
guys you just got to see the movie yes
but every story is based on looked up
look up
Steven Clancy Hall on Wikipedia yeah and
that will give you there he also did an
investigation discovery show on it
apparently although I couldn't find it
for free like - because I was looking
for it this morning like to see if I
could watch it like on YouTube but I
couldn't find it
yeah it's good flicks how they met on a
[ __ ] shoot
yeah and they became Fred's and then
they went to work for this [ __ ]
really [ __ ] shitty porn studio where
they lived on site in the studio yeah it
was like a big warehouse
yeah and they had a bunch of other
people living in it and I'm not sure if
all the girls lived in it but I think
all the most lived in it
yeah some of them did I some of them did
yeah and some of them like did other
things too like other than being mopes
that's like so cuz you guys um the guy
like the guy's real name the the black
guy was his real name was Steven
like I said Steven Clancy hall but his
porn name was Steve driver yeah and the
other guy was his porn name was Tom dong
yeah even though I think his real name
was Harold long or Howard Wong I can't
remember sort of an age but yeah so they
started off getting kicked in the nuts
that's what their that's what their
specialty was get kicked in the nuts
yeah
okay so basically it's it's weird
because like I said this I I looked up
the real case like after this and the
movie actually does stick to the real
case to a large degree and but it just
kind of like made funnier but the
situation itself is I guess so funny but
also like kind of [ __ ] up that it's
like you can't like help but laugh at it
so it's like these two guys basically
they're like in the beginning it's kind
of like an inspirational movie kind of
way because these two guys are like
basically like porn geeks like when they
meet each other like on this random like
[ __ ] shoot and they kind of like bond
over their shared love of porn and
they're really their wish to be like the
world's best porn star they want to be
like on the covers of the DVDs and
everything like that this happened in
2010 by the way so you're almost kind of
like they want to start their business
they have all their their standard like
over the hill Los Angeles look and it's
like we're gonna be the biggest porn
stars ever if you like yeah you go man
you know what I mean even though they
you know they're not what you would
normally think of as like being a porn
star you know what I mean it's like
they're kind of skinny and it's like
apparently they don't have big dicks or
anything like that so it's like they
kind of get you know [ __ ] on by
everywhere they go they're not real
they're not real creative either they
try to come up with these innovations
but they're just stupid as [ __ ] yeah and
it's it's like been an endearing way
because it's like you can see they want
to do it so badly but they don't really
do what they're doing they're trying to
come up with new [ __ ] but it just
doesn't work yeah that's kind of like I
said and I think that the this movie did
it really well because it's like you you
think that you know they they came up
with all these silly things like you
know the dick is the hotdog bun and
monster hands or like a second hand
chicken and stuff like that and it's
like you would think but it's like the
movie isn't really making fun of them
it's just kind of like showing how these
were two guys who had a dream they were
just kind of clueless and they don't
really know what they were doing and you
kind of feel sorry for them because
everyone is just telling them how much
they suck and all the only job they can
get is this like really low-rent [ __ ]
porn studio called ultimate DVD which I
guess is it was a real studio I don't
know if it's
around and they kind of like specialized
in these kind of bottom-of-the-barrel
fetish videos like armpit sniffing and
you know get guys getting kicked in the
balls and you know was they had one guy
whose name was poo Casso which you know
use your imagination yeah we have all
the [ __ ] scat [ __ ] - yeah like that
was another thing like they kind of let
them be in some of the scenes yeah their
balls kicked and stuff but then they
also have to like clean up the sets
afterward and yeah all this other kind
of crowd and when they did have to
perform and have sex they did that then
you just got to see it yes but I'll tell
you it's like this is much like any
night this was a lot more explicit than
Boogie Nights yeah um this is pretty
much just all it's damn near x-rated
nudity yeah and it's like they don't
really I mean they don't really show
it's not x-rated as if they don't show
like a wreck penis is raised like that
but they show pretty much everything but
that um and you know what's going on
right so it's like they don't really try
to hide it like one review that I was
reading of this which was actually a
very positive review this actually um
premiered at Sundance literally last
year like January 2019 but I think it
only just came to like streaming maybe
like a month or two ago because it's I
haven't seen it play they're asking why
do I have form I saw it on X we ran it
on Xbox which means you can probably run
it on YouTube as well I would and maybe
Amazon and I and it only had one review
on it when we were viewed it so it was
new to Xbox yes I said it's been
streaming for a month or so uh I'm not
really sure when it came on is the third
time I saw it yeah I don't remember
seeing it on there like prior to this
but it was kind of down the list and
usually they put the newer ones up
toward the top so maybe it was just
there we didn't see it because usually
we do we just kind of scroll through the
horror and sci-fi but this one we were
just always Chandra's yeah I think it
was new I think it was new I think it's
only been there for a few days
yeah but like I said it's Bennet it
premiered at a festival like a long time
ago right more than a year ago but I
think it was new for Xbox yeah but maybe
it only just got a distributor because
this really does seem like a movie it's
a great [ __ ] movie but it really does
seem like one that is going to find it
difficult to get a distributor I would
think just
because of the subject matter and I mean
this is not a mainstream site now maybe
not just because of all the nudity and
all of the you know disgusting [ __ ]
that's in it but also because it's a
comedy but then there's also a horrible
it's also a horrible tree crime it's a
low-budget movie it's shot very well it
has very good acting in it really good
storytelling it's [ __ ] hilarious
it gets tragic at the end but then it in
the end it's a it's a story about
friendship and it was also spent away
there's also story about mental illness
yeah big-time
because there's a lot of delusion
involved yeah driver okay and he and in
real life he had a history of mental
illness that he did weird [ __ ]
yeah which I don't want a [ __ ] spoil
the movie but once he got something in
his mind he started to become very
delusional about what his abilities were
going to be get very unrealistic
standards for himself which i think is
what made him more sympathetic but also
you I mean he was scary but you also
kind of like felt sorry for him yes he
just had like no he just started losing
his grip on reality
yeah as people as he kept getting [ __ ]
on by you know the the industry that he
really wanted to succeed in and it just
like realizing that he wasn't going to
be what he wanted to be and not asserted
not only did he want to be a porn star
at this time he also liked kung fu' and
martial arts stuff and he was big into
that which that factors in yeah he
wanted to be a damn fighter pilot he
wanted to be all kinds of stuff but he
just because of who he was and how he
was and his mental issues he just he was
never gonna be that yeah and uh I think
that's what may that sounded sad part I
mean other than he had their line that
was roughly that he had really great
ambitions but he just didn't have the
ability to cash in on that and he
couldn't get it done and he couldn't
deal with that good deal of the fact
that he wasn't going to succeed yeah
which I kind of understand I mean I get
that
makes make some very sympathetic it does
because there's a difference between a
dude who there's nothing to him and he
just sits on the [ __ ] couch yeah I
mean that's one thing this dude was
actually trying
he was just trying and failing yeah
which man that that's that's that's
rough and it was yeah it was
heartbreaking you know it's really a
heartbreaking and I'm not like excusing
what he did because that was super
[ __ ] up but yeah he's like mentally
ill yeah you can see how I mean he
wasn't a mean person he just didn't have
like I said he didn't have a solid grip
on reality and people did try to help
him I mean and they did kind of show in
the movie and I guess you know his
parents had actually tried to help him
as well because they knew that he had
problems but he he made mistakes that
were just so basic yeah yeah I mean that
any person we think got a sense would
know not to do with the kind of [ __ ]
that he was doing but that kinda is
that's what this movie is about you know
I mean he they were interesting
characters they were kind of endearing
and they were also fuck-ups yeah and and
they were trying though yeah you know I
mean he's like I said it's they had a
dream yeah but it's just they didn't
have I mean Tom dong you know yeah the
other guy he was actually a slightly
more successful he was actually in some
horror movies yeah and he was he could
be an accountant and he was a web
designer he actually could do stuff yeah
you know in a way he was just as
delusional but I think he kind of came
to a point where he understood that it's
like look this you know I want to do
this but I'm not good at it so maybe I
should just you know kind of you know
find something else to do or do
something that I'm better at or he
seemed to at some point he seemed to
feel like it was okay that it's like you
know if I to be in porn which is what he
wanted to do you know if I have to be in
these movies where women are kicking me
in the balls or you know I have to do
this and that then he was willing to do
that and so he had kind of come to terms
with the fact that he was not going to
be like the next John Holmes or the next
ron jeremy or anything like that which
is what they wanted to do at the
beginning they want to start there
business they wanted to do this that the
other but like I said they just didn't
really have and I think there was a
point to where you know Steve driver was
kind of I mean obviously he was becoming
a liability because of his you know
delusions yeah and his anger issues his
inability to deal with you know
rejection is inability to deal with you
know him not being able to get what he
wanted yeah and now he was not the Rudy
ray Moore of porn now Rudy ray was very
talented he was just working with a very
small budget he didn't have what you
doing poop and Rudy Ray had a smaller
budget and he knew how to make a very
entertaining movie on a small budget
well it really was actually pretty good
he knew to like get film students who
you at least kind of knew what they were
doing like with lighting and even though
it wasn't you know I was successful I
wouldn't even call it exactly I wouldn't
even call these guys the ed woods of
porn and could actually get a movie done
that they were even less than that they
were even they were they I think ed Wood
was a genius compared to these guys
yeah and I mean the thing is they just
they at first they just wanted to be in
porn yeah and then when they kind of
found out that it was harder than they
thought or you know they they weren't
going to be able to hack it then they
kind of went the direction well maybe we
should start our own porter company but
they weren't real successful at that
either
like you said because they didn't have
great ideas about how to film things
they didn't have you know they were very
amateurish yeah they did not have the
genes they were not genetically endowed
for poor that too and then like I said
they kind of got you know and I'm not
saying there's you know there's [ __ ]
so many porn genre that pretty much
anybody that looks like anything and
like yeah but you're not going to be
like a household name you know is they
were Jerry they wanted to be on the
covers of the right hands and they
wanted they want any light Awards and
they wanted a female fantasies they
wanted to be female fan yeah they're
saying that they wanted women to have
like posters of yeah their walls I'm
like I never met any woman ever ahead of
the world serve a porn star right yeah I
don't think very doing a female porn
star but
very delusional thinking I think other
than like the the famous ones like for
the 70s and 80s I can't even think of a
male porn star that I'm whose name I
know off who's that one who's not one
guy Jeremy no not ron jeremy this guy
was a more recent guy [ __ ] man i don't
remember like but i I can't even like
remember yeah many women don't don't
give a [ __ ] about for not not normally
they like that the novels the written
erotica they look like I said yeah a
women tend to leg erotica I've kind of
talked about that before because like I
said you can use your imagination and
insert you ever you want to insert it in
there and they'll foreign stars are only
famous within yeah right and the thing
is when you when they do straight porn
it doesn't really matter what the dudes
look like now looking at him because
that's not who the dudes are that's why
I post the women are hot but the dudes
are just like they can show not or maybe
they're not it's like it doesn't really
matter so like I said and they kind of
showed that I mean I know that in this
movie they were showing ultimate DVD
which was kind of considered even in the
foreign world was considered like bottom
of the barrel like chief oh [ __ ] and
they were doing like weird fetish she
kind of [ __ ] like you know [ __ ] feet
and everything which isn't really that
weird nowadays but um this one that long
would go this way yeah it was 2010 I
mean it but still I guess it was still
back then considered maybe a niche thing
especially in LA well in LA that that
was just considered to be bottom of the
barrel cheap porn you didn't have to pay
people much for it yeah it wasn't being
considered to be edgy they didn't
consider to be porn yeah they consider
real porn to have you know I'm to my
silicone sister on [ __ ] level 10 with
a [ __ ] roided-out dude on a [ __ ]
expensive set that's what they consider
yeah because they would write like this
big huge the other have arms yeah
[ __ ] pirate ships and [ __ ] and
they're still looking yeah [ __ ]
Pirates of the Caribbean theme it's just
that's like like the [ __ ] top notch
high dollar [ __ ] porn industry they
were making that is real mainstream yeah
real mainstream and everybody look like
a ten or less
and in this movie it's like even in the
opening scene like where you know Steve
driver and Tom Dom met each other you
know they met each other like on a
[ __ ] set like I said so there was
like one hot woman like laying in the
middle and then just all these like ugly
[ __ ] lay like like old man like
just a nerd and they're all standing
around in the air like try that like and
she was the ten either though she was
more like a seventh she was not I mean
compared to like she was all stuff like
in the porn world she would have been
maybe one step above a moat that's there
you know
well yeah it's real yeah but um yeah so
seriously like I said now don't expect
this to be like you know fun and laughs
the whole way through it is very funny
um David Arquette is in this as he's
kind of like a producer of like more
like bigger or mainstream porn and these
two managed to like kind of wangle their
way into like an audition or like doing
a movie with him and it doesn't go well
but um so he's so he's really funny in
it too and that's kind of like one of
the catalysts that like makes them
realize that they're never gonna like
make it in like the maybe you know the
major foreign world because it's like
they don't have what it takes and they
just kind of thing and like I said I'm
all I'm gonna say is monster hands and
chicken hands it's just [ __ ] nuts I
laughed so hard it's like but yeah so
like I said it's it's kind of like
Boogie Nights in the sense that you know
a lot of it's fun and a lot of it's
funny but then like as it goes on it
gets like sadder and sadder like more
and more tragic and as I said the the
director who's nameless Luke is hanging
I just looked it up um that was like a
really I think it's like a really
audacious movie because it's really hard
to pull off a shift in tone that
striking and still have it be a really
good movie and I have to say that this
movie was I think it was an hour and 48
minutes an hour and fifty minutes it
flew by yeah I mean it seemed really
sure and the two dudes
two dudes that star in it I couldn't
name them I don't know who that is but
they did a great job just the chemistry
between them was it so good I put this
movie up there with like artist
self-defense
although out of the two I would watch
art of self-defense first but this is a
good movie too if you like [ __ ]
Boogie Nights you'd like this if you'd
like art of self-defense you'd like this
yes similar kind of a tone as a heart of
self-defense kind of yeah I know
self-defense was a little bit dryer yeah
our humor that yeah that was like more
of like a sarcastic or more like a black
comedy yeah I'm not sure it's kind of
hard to say like this is sort of IIIi
would hesitate to say it's funny because
when we were like looking cuz you know
when you have rent things on xbox and
probably on YouTube - I don't remember
but it tells you like the title and how
long it is and then I'll say what the
genre is the genre on this one said
other other yes and like I thought I was
like yeah I guess they can figure it out
either because it's like it's ostensibly
a comedy but it's not a comedy because
it's funny but it's like based on a
horrible true crime and it gets really
sad and it's like really really tragic
at the end but it still kind of works
it's one of the best movies we've read
reprinted I really really love yeah yeah
I mean I did I mean if you liked Boogie
Nights and you're ready for there to be
like these weird channel shifts like
that which there were kind of where I'm
Boogie Nights do cuz a lot of horrible
[ __ ] happen to that as well
then this would be right up your alley
like I said it's it's almost like a porn
film in itself like I said there's not
yeah there's not like a wreck dicks or
anything like that there are some dicks
and it's like it's pretty you know
graphic and detects going those are
dicks in it but um and and the way they
shoot it I guess kind of to get across
how you know bottom-of-the-barrel this
particular studio was its it always
looks like really unappealing and like
gross and rowdy and stuff like that and
like I said the fetish [ __ ] that they're
shooting it's like you know them showing
them scrubbing up like the
OOP after like that's cat born and stuff
like that it's gotta be like the worst
[ __ ] job but it's like the people
that live there because they live there
and I guess some of the other like
people that were in the movies lived
there as well like in this big just
warehouse complex where they had like
all these little rooms that were sets
and whatnot and then they had these
people living there like in bunk beds
like in little dorms and they would you
know you'd be in the movies but then you
would have to do other [ __ ] too like
they have one person that would cook and
you'd have one person like how to clean
up sets afterward which has to be like
one of the worst jobs ever cleaning a
porn set after the [ __ ] movie Wow but
yeah what's next everything else to talk
about
um I don't think so but yeah it's like
if you know just seriously rent this
movie because this was a surprise we
just kind of like chose it randomly
I saw the poster of it and the poster
looks but looked good and when I said
genre other and then we said that was
intriguing
I looked at the trailer and we're like
oh okay yeah yeah watch the trailer and
I was like yeah so we watched it because
I was like I for some reason I liked
movies about the porn industry like I
said I loved Boogie Nights that's like
one of my favorite movies well-written
is road well-written movie yeah
hilarious and sad and you'll just to go
through so many emotions and look like I
said another review I was read it said
it's like this is like the most fun and
most like you know soul-crushing quickly
yeah we'll see oh yeah I think you'll be
the shower afterwards but also it's kind
of funny and terrible
but yeah so uh seriously seek it out if
you're into that kind of stuff because I
just really loved it and honestly I'd
watch it again today
um oh we saw another trailer too for a
South African horror movie yeah that's
good really good maybe we'll do a
matinee on that on Wednesday because
maybe we can watch that cider tomorrow
yeah that looks pretty kick-ass too but
yeah so I guess we'll wrap it up since
it's just like a little movie review so
uh thanks everybody for coming by and
we'll talk to you guys again we'll
probably do another live stream on
Wednesday like I said probably we'll do
another movie so we'll see you on
Wednesday
okay come on so fully the